c'est une première pour pékin après des
jours de ce mode la capitale chinoise a
annoncé sa toute première alerte rouge
les taux de pollution n'est pas ce du 10
fois le plafond recommandé par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé des
mesures exceptionnelles ont également
été annoncé l'arrêt de tous les
chantiers de construction
la fermeture d'écoles et des
restrictions très strict touchant la
circulation automobile
une pollution qui rappelle aux
négociateurs à la conférence de paris
qu'il y a aussi des préoccupations liées
à la santé qui sont en jeu l' oms
prévoit que si rien n'est fait pour
réduire la hausse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre il y aura imaginez-vous
250 mille décès annuellement entre 2030
et 2050 directement liés au changement
climatique michel bonsoir bonsoir c'est
les chiffres qui font assez alarmant
mais alors parlons de cet impact sur la
santé de 130 on voit ces images de pékin
oui ça tous ces gens absolument on prend
on parle beaucoup de l'environnement on
parle beaucoup de l'économie dans le
changement climatique mais la santé est
également très très présente dans les
enjeux le ms dit que ça coûtera 2 2 à 4
milliards de dollars de plus pour les
systèmes de santé dans le monde dès 2030
donc c'est véritablement important d'y
penser
regardons ensemble quels sont les
impacts santé donc comme l'image de
pékin les maladies respiratoires et
cardiovasculaires seront en hausse
asthme problèmes cardiaques majeurs dont
les factures liées à la chaleur souvent
malnutrition donc une diminution de la
quantité de la nourriture disponible et
de l'eau également santé mentale quand
il y aura des grandes chaleurs problèmes
de santé mentale dépression le choc post
traumatique qui lie maladies
transmissibles à céline
on n'a qu'à penser qu'à la malaria à la
dengue aux vierges tout sera sans
évidemment les enfants les personnes
âgées sont plus vulnérables dans ces
situations absolument et dans des dans
des incidents de chaleur c'est surtout
les personnes âgées
on se souvient en 2003 en france et en
europe il y avait eu 20
laissez la majorité d'entre eux étaient
des personnes âgées alors qu'est ce que
propose la prestigieuse revue de lancer
ce qu'elle sait pencher là dessus pour
minimiser ses impacts
alors c'est un groupe de chercheurs
autour de l'un des sites qui proposent
dix recommandations aux gens de la
conférence de paris
regardons quatre d'entre elles alors
tout d'abord on parlait justement des
maladies cardiovasculaires et
pulmonaires ce serait limitation du
charbon pékin est un très bon exemple
aujourd'hui ensuite les systèmes de
santé alors dans un premier temps ils
doivent se modifier s'adapter et il se
financer en fonction de ces changements
climatiques là et ils doivent se parler
entre eux donc avoir beaucoup plus une
organisation complète face aux
changements climatiques et en dernier de
tout prévoir un meilleur style de vie
dont la question du transport en commun
est assez central alors espérons que
tout ça va être entendu à la conférence
de l'est